this is the twilight zone I would
recommend start with enough time at last
which is the burgess Meredith library
wants to be alone with his book and he
gets his wish basically and then his
glass is great I remember as a little
kid being like oh my god what's it gonna
do you know I just love her spirit if
there's an actor - and that was the
check well-designed episode love the one
where the guy just wants to be left
alone to read books and then break his
glasses time enough at last yeah about
the man who wants to be left alone with
his books and then yes because that's
the thing right with all the Twilight
Zone episodes is everything's always
flipped on its head and everybody ends
up on the other side of specifically
what they want or definitely did not
watch everything that happens in this
universe has to be the way it is things
happen when he should my favorite
Twilight Zone episode which is the
monsters are doing Maple Street which is
really classic Twilight Zone what was
that a meteor there's one called
long-distance phone call about a
grandmother who gives her grandson a toy
phones and they can communicate and then
she passes and they continue to
communicate and then there was one about
a department store where the mannequins
come to life at night and after seeing
that I just assumed that's what happens
in the apartment source okay miss I
wonder if you
beauty is in the eye of the beholder at
the pig mask point where the woman has
wrapped and then one that was less scary
and more touching that I just loved was
betrayed ins and that was the older
couple that get a hard sell from
somebody that's company where you get to
trade in to get a new body because
they're both nearing the end and the
price they're quoted at they save up
their money and they get so excited and
they're like we're gonna be together
forever now because we'll just keep
trading it again in your body and they
find out that it was actually the prices
I'll quote for one doesn't seem
realistic a kind of stopwatch is a
really excellent episode something tells
me this is a very unusual watch the
dummy is really good if you watch those
like three episodes and you don't like
them then the twilight zone is for you
those are really kind of iconic
groundbreaking you're gonna want to
listen to me it will repeat itself do
you get it
I saved us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]